[Music]
hi i'm kevin konink i'm
from belgium
i work as an auditor at the european
court of auditors
having background as an author at
regional or local level i
i thought it was very interesting to
join the court because it's a relatively
small institution it deals with a lot of
policy areas whether it's agriculture
cohesion i felt like it would enable me
to to get a good understanding of the
whole
new project
[Music]
previously i was working in brussels
which is of course bigger but i have to
say that i was really surprised by
luxembourg it offers a lot of
opportunities it's smaller but it has
all the advantages that the capital has
i think the court offers excellent
training opportunities you're also
surrounded with a lot of knowledgeable
colleagues who are happy to share their
knowledge
[Music]
it's true that we spent quite a bit of
time in the office to prepare audits to
prepare reports to analyze documents
but we also go on the spot because we
feel it's important to see how projects
are being implemented and how the money
is being spent on the spot
[Music]
to be able to see how management and
control systems work in different member
states how the budget is being
implemented across the member states and
even outside the eu and to be able to
compare those systems and draw lessons
from one member state and maybe to apply
it in another
a small part of a much bigger chain but
in my role as an auditor i'm able to
contribute by auditing and communicating
the results of our audits so citizens
know how their money is being spent
[Applause]